all right Ryan Rainbow six siege has
hijacked all of our battlefield
conversations of late so it's fitting
that we talk about the new black ice TLC
which adds a new map yacht and adds two
new characters book and frost so
starting off let's talk about buck buck
the Canadian how do you feel about that
under barrel shotgun so buck is an
attacker he's got the c8 sfw assault
rifle which is sort of like an m4 type
of thing and he's got the ca mrs which
is a DMR rifle and his special ability
is that he has an under barrel shotgun
mounted on both of them so what do you
think that he's good at and what is he
bad as a new operator the under barrel
shotgun is called the skeleton key and
that made me think prior to playing it
that this would be another way of
getting into places yeah he kind of
seemed like a door preacher and it turns
out that not really the shotgun is maybe
one or two hits to a floor breach it's
three to a standard door and it doesn't
go through castles walls it'll put a
nice hole in a wall or a garage door but
it won't go through them like sledge so
in terms of the usefulness really at the
end of the day all you get is an extra
shotgun on the character now where he
seemed to kind of shine is as a range
support so I think one things you can do
with him is grab his marksman rifle and
hang back with class and then try and
pick people off from afar and unlike
glass or maybe even twitch if you make
the decision to go with her marksman
rifle you do have the option later to
run in with a shotgun so you're not
added the same disadvantages on the
other characters where you have to
commit to their weapon but it comes at a
cost I agree I think that you will find
that this will be good for some players
who like to be that clutch player who
runs in at the end of the match in the
last 15 seconds and gets the job done
you might see that more with buck than
you might from some of the other classes
and what I kind of like about buck is
somebody who's been playing a lot of
ranked play lately buck is a good sort
of early scout early couple of rounds
operator because of the versatility of
the weapons you don't necessarily know
what kind of engaged
you're gonna get into and he should be
able to feel out the enemy but I don't
think you're going to be using buck
later in the match my overall impression
of buck is he's not that much better
than a recruit i think i would consider
him just your customizable recruit at
the expense of a gadget laden iphone
Brooks on the bottom now frost the other
character she's a game changer because
her welcome mat literally changes how
everybody else has to play on the map
the welcome mat is basically a giant
bear trap sands bear and you can put it
at the bottom of ladders you can put it
underneath windows you can put it in
barbed wire and anything that's volta
Bowl people won't see it until they're
over it and then it's a completely one
hit disabled / round ender if it's the
last person alive your jumps onto it
yeah I think frost is super fun the
super 90 shotgun is solid it's as good
as some of the other shotguns in the
game the welcome mat is at least now
something the players don't necessarily
look for yet and it seems to be way more
effective than say captains way too
obvious way too easy to find trap if it
remains as effective as it's been in the
last two days of playing the game then
you will see frost every time on the
enemy I would immediately put her in the
Tier one operator category with mute and
some of the other people who just really
make a giant difference you are a
defender that becomes a hunter let's
talk about the new map yacht you're
gonna have to talk about it because I
played for the entire night and never
saw it how did you feel about the new
map I think yacht is pretty freaking
cool it's definitely one of the most
visually impressive maps in the game on
the exterior it's a luxury yacht that
has been stuck in an ice cap and off to
one side a nuclear submarine has
surfaced through the ice where
presumably our operators are deploying
from and the yacht is
as perhaps survived a storm like there
are there is snow inside of the yacht
there is damage to the hull and it
creates an environment that is both cold
feeling and varied and design similar to
how cafe dostoevsky has like you know
the kitchen and the back hallways where
the laundry room is but it also has
these really nice areas like the bar
that give the feeling of the environment
of variety I like the fact that it's
kind of a more fantastical scenario some
of the criticism that I had of the way
some of the master design on cj's just
canal was you know you walk into canal
and you look up to the left and there's
amazing crash ship that you could have a
fight on but you end up having it in the
building to the right so I think it's
good that they're adding more unique
locations with kind of more tom clancy
like stories to write and this one is
one that does immediately have that feel
i was a brief impression of the new dlc
black ice for Rainbow six siege yacht is
available now for everybody [ __ ]
froster out for season pass holders and
will be available for everybody else on
februari 9th for more coverage of
Rainbow six siege stay tuned at gamespot
com todd secured initiate extraction not
required about
for eliminated friendly mission
successful